i said to my colleagues one day in the
editorial room
um why do we seem to have a double
standard
and there was a terrible silence and i
realized at that moment that i'd crossed
a line
i had no idea what the line was or why
i'd crossed it but i realized
i'd stop being one of them and i'd
become
one of you
i'm dave rubin and this is the ruben
report as always guys click
that subscribe button on youtube and
don't forget to tap that notification
bell so you're alerted of our new videos
and joining me today is a journalist
author and columnist for the times of
london
melanie phillips welcome to the reuben
report
thanks dave very good to be with you i'm
glad to have you because i mentioned to
you right before we started here that
for about two years i've been getting
emails and tweets and facebook messages
and all sorts of things people saying
you gotta talk
to this melanie phillips now you're in
jerusalem now but you also split
time in london for for my american
audience that may not know you
can you just do a little melanie
phillips 101 a little a little bio
before we get into the specifics of
of your work your writing your speaking
your books that sort of thing
sure sure well i am a british jew
born and bred in london of parents who
were themselves
uh born and bred in london had a fairly
conventional
upbringing of the type that british jews
in the 1950s had
parents not very religious not very
observant but nevertheless
belonged to an orthodox synagogue
i went to oxford university and read
english literature which fits you for
everything and nothing and
fell into journalism i was
trained though in those days journalists
were actually trained
and we were taught things like
objectivity and
the need to be truthful and the need to
be factual
and the need to separate fact from
opinion would you believe such a thing
and i spent two years learning all these
uh
trade crafts on a local newspaper in
britain we have
national newspapers we don't have
syndicated columns like you do
but i was on a local newspaper in the
suburbs of london
and then went to a magazine and then
went to the guardian
the guardian is a bit like the new york
times but more so
it is the kind of journalistic crucible
of left-wing thinking in britain and
at the time that i went there i didn't
ever really consider myself to be
left-wing
but because i wasn't very ideological i
consider myself to be a liberal now i
know that the word liberal
means something different in america
from britain but what i meant by that
what i mean by that was that i thought
of myself as an
old-fashioned liberal that is to say
somebody who believes
in uh making a better world uh by making
people
uh uh by by prioritizing the good
that people do over the bad standing up
for
the vulnerable against abuses of power
standing up for truth rather than lies
and
at that time i thought that my
colleagues at the guardian
and in the left that we were all on the
same side
and we can talk about this in detail uh
but nevertheless
over the next few years i realized that
uh this was a big mistake
and that while i still believed in all
those things they were on the other side
they were the people who actually were
the oppressors of the poor and
vulnerable they were themselves
racist and anti-semitic and during this
period which took
10 20 years um i changed also
in the sense that i became more aware of
my jewish background my jewish identity
became more important to me
and i became very very aware of the
enormity of the big lies being told
about
israel would you believe i'd never
been to israel and never wanted to go
until about the year 2000
the year 2000 was the first time i went
and i didn't particularly like it
for various reasons and then within two
or three years
i had bought a place in jerusalem
because my life
and my whole view of the world and my
view of myself as a british jew
had completely changed so that's a very
short
thumbnail sketch of my descent from
being the kind of
wise child of the left being the
she-devil of the western hemisphere
yeah well i'm not sure how much you know
about my story but i think a lot of my
audience is going dave
we've kind of heard this before because
that in many ways although
we're not the same age we're not from
the same country uh the story that you
just told of coming from the left
from a largely jewish secular family i
mean it's very much the same story and i
think in many ways
our politics and the way you laid out
what true liberalism is
really really do line up so can you talk
a little bit because i get this question
constantly now can you talk about when
and why you started to see the split
within the left towards socialism
progressivism whatever you want to call
it
versus the liberalism that you just
described
yes well there was one particular
punctuation mark
which really set me on this path and it
was in 1982
and it was when in a conversation with
my colleagues at the guardian i was an
editorial writer and um i thought of
them
as being just like me uh liberal in the
best sense
uh committed to truth and reason
and decent people and
uh we had a conversation in which i was
very troubled
by what at the time seemed to me to be
the disproportionate attention
being paid to what israel was doing in
its war in lebanon
which was a controversial war but it was
being portrayed falsely
as a war of aggression whereas i knew
and don't forget i'd never been to
israel and didn't really want to go and
wasn't really my thing but i
knew that it was trying to root out the
palestinian liberation organization and
stop it from attacking
israelis and the plo at that time was in
southern lebanon but it was being
represented falsely as a war of
aggression and
at the same time out of the woodwork
came unbridled anti-semitism that
we british jews are all considered to be
basically all sticking together in a
clannish kind of way and defending
israel
and i was very troubled by this and i
was very troubled by the fact that
the guardian was spending such a
disproportionate amount of its time
in hurling terrible uh uh
obloquy at israel over all this whereas
at the same time
president assad the father of the
current president assad
had caused a massacre
of his political opponents something in
between 15
and 40 000 of his opponents uh were
killed over the course of a couple of
weeks and that story didn't really have
much traction at the guardian i
i couldn't understand i was different
person then didn't really get
understand what i was dealing with and i
said to my colleagues one day in the
editorial room
um why do we seem to have a double
standard
and there was a terrible silence and i
realized at that moment that i'd crossed
a line i had no idea what the line was
or why i'd crossed it but i realized
i'd stop being one of them and i'd
become
one of you and they said
well of course there's a double standard
after all they said to me
like you and i became you and by you
they meant
israel and i'd never been to israel like
you
we in the west are brought up to believe
in the sanctity of life respect for
human rights human dignity
whereas people in the developing world
are not brought up to believe
any of those things and so if they kill
people we cannot judge them by our
standards
that would be racism and i thought
what and i said to them what are you
saying that if one is unfortunate enough
to be born and
bred into the developing world
then one does not then have the same
rights to life and liberty
that we do to my mind
that's racism and they said why are you
so upset
we do you and i became you again the
great honor
of assuming that you are like us
uh you have the same moral standards as
us and what's more
you tell us that you as the jewish
people
are morally superior to us now that
is a untrue and b
it is sheer anti-semitism and at that
moment i realized that the assumption
i'd made
that we were all marching under the same
banner
of truth and freedom and decency and all
those good
things that was untrue that i was
marching under that banner
but they were on the other side they
the liberals the left the people who
assumed that because they were the
liberals on the left they
embodied virtue and everybody who was
not the liberals in the left
was a bad and evil person they were the
racists
they were the anti-semites and they
believed in lies and they were
irrational
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell